Was it the right choice to make?
I had something I wanted to do before the festival, and
it was just that Mr. Uesugi recognized
me. I feel like everything will pay off.
I wish we could be in a relationship,
but I feel like I have
to find an answer, and everything for today
is over.  Music]
Look,
Fuutarou is a special person to me, so I
don't remember giving you permission to enter the room He's here,
why is this meaningless, but I can't
give up I
might not be able to come to the school festival anymore,
so now  Don't listen to the answer Those
guys were always at full power
Next
is my bread
Movie The Quintessential
Quintuplets Released May 20th